a couple of months ago a friend of mine
innocuously dropped the line I think I
gotta read The Art of War to get better
at Apex 500 hours is just not cutting it
and I did what any good friend would do
I mercilessly made fun of him for saying
something so stupid there's no way a 2
000 year old book could possibly help on
a pixelated battlefield but that got me
thinking what if my friend in all his
stupidity was actually onto something
what if reading Sun Tzu's Timeless
classic could actually make you better
at video games so I decided to stop by
my local bookstore after work and pick
up a copy of the Art of War hello and
welcome to Gamespot no HUD the show
where we Tinker with games to create new
and interesting experiences however
today we aren't changing the game no the
game is changing us
[Music]
now I'll be honest I play a lot of
Shooters I've put in well over a
thousand hours into Call of Duty over
the many years and I used to play a ton
of Rainbow Six Siege but I wouldn't say
I'm good at Shooters I have decent
reflexes and I have a basic
understanding of tactics but I'm the
type of player that gets swept up in the
moment and I run out into the open and
die obviously my tactics do
differentiate from game to game but I
can be a little hot-headed it's also
worth mentioning that I've never read
The Art of War sure I know quotes from
it I'm pretty sure back when Call of
Duty used to throw quotes up on the
screen after you died they had a few Sun
Tzu quotes but I couldn't tell you what
they were or what they meant all that to
say I believe that my complete lack of
culture and FPS mediocrity makes me the
perfect subject for this little
experiment so here's the plan I'm going
to read The Art of War a few times I'm
gonna do my best to extract the major
tactics Sun Tzu outlines and do my best
to retrofit them into playerunknown's
Battlegrounds why Pub G well a major
theme that runs through the Art of War
is how a commander or Soldier reacts to
different situations the warrior shapes
his victory from the dining Dynamic of
the enemy war is unpredictable and so is
Pub G the ever tightening map means I
won't always know the battlefield the
random assortment of weapons means I
won't be able to control my flow of
resources and the slower Pace means I
can think through confrontations the
Call of Duties are a bit too predictable
the rainbow sixes are a bit too
fast-paced and the fortnite's are just
not my thing
additionally I've played over 300 hours
of Pub G so I have a pretty good idea of
my current skill level now
it's time to read
[Music]
after three read-throughs and copious
amounts of notes I think I've arrived at
a foolproof procedure derived from this
book to ensure success in a virtual
Battlefield
foreign
I call it the flow chart of War but
before we delve into the secrets of
success we must first set the stage what
exactly is the Art of War the book
consists of 13 chapters that break down
different aspects and phases of warfare
that range from diplomacy to
moment-to-moment tactics fight downhill
do not swallow bait be ready for the
unexpected and so on some of the
examples the text uses are a bit dated
however many of the ideas are still
relevant today famous generals such as a
Napoleon Bonaparte even cited Sun Tzu's
work but like most Classics The Art of
War proved to be controversial why
because Sun Tzu embraced deception this
didn't sit well with the followers of
Confucianism they believe that deception
even in Warfare goes against the very
values of Confucius those opinions
didn't stand the test of time though
nearly two Millennia later The Art of
War remains one of the most influential
military texts of all time but what
tactics if any could hold water on a
virtual Battlefield well let's start
with Sun Tzu's five steps of War
measurement estimation calculation
comparison and victory measurement
determines estimation estimation
determines calculation calculation
determines comparison and comparison
determines Victory the way I see it a
general or leader needs to First measure
the terrain estimate the enemy's
strength calculate all the available
options and compare our situation with
the enemies easy enough but how do I
translate this into Pub G to make things
simple let's think of measurement as
geography this encompasses the terrain
the circle and our location within or
outside the circle estimation is threat
assessment how many enemy Squad members
are there what kind of weapons and armor
are they rocking and what level of
tactics are they employing calculation
is Battle plan if I were to engage how
would I go about doing it comparison is
well comparison how does the enemy
situation stack up against my situation
now if I've accurately assessed the
situation then I should come out
Victorious Know The Enemy know yourself
and Victory is never in doubt not in 100
Battles given the nature of pubg once
I've run my tactical test on a threat I
have two options aggression or avoidance
the skillful Warrior attacks so that the
enemy cannot defend he defends so that
the enemy cannot attack I will only take
the aggressive route if I have the
perceived tactical advantage or if
there's no other option if I have no
perceived advantage and I can avoid the
altercation then I will this is where
warfare's psychological factors take
root though I should assume that the
enemy is also thinking this way sure
they probably won't have a whole damn
chart like me but at some level the
fight-or-flight mentality is going to
kick in if we are clearly overpowering
them they will flee if they are
overpowering us then they will push
that's human nature and human nature is
predictable and predictability can be
exploited with deception my perceived
Advantage is even more advantageous if
my enemies believe they have the
advantage
[Music]
when able feign inability law with bait
strike with chaos war is founded on
Deception the best way to deceive is to
be unpredictable his form is visible but
I am formless I am concentrated he is
divided I feel like we are missing
something though aggression and
avoidance assume that the insurgents are
always going to be hostile maybe there's
a third option we could take diplomacy
Sun Tzu frequently points out that
conflicts can be won without setting
foot on the battlefield and in most
cases those are the greatest victories
of all ultimate Excellence lies not in
winning every battle but in defeating
the enemy without ever fighting the
highest form of warfare is to attack
strategy itself now anyone who's been in
a Call of Duty Lobby knows that
diplomacy can be a bit fickle among
Gamers the shoot first attitude is
hardwired into our brains most games
even reward that kind of thinking with
scoreboards challenges and flashy Point
systems I myself am guilty of pulling a
virtual trigger without giving too much
thought to the consequences of my
actions that's going to have to change
when possible I will do my very best to
disarm combatants through the art of
persuasion now keep in mind just because
I want to cooperate with other players
doesn't mean I can let my guard down
there can only be one winner and any
truce forged on the battlefield is a
temporary means to an end eventually
I'll have to kill them but I'll wait
until they are of no use to me if
diplomacy fails and it will bullets will
fly however if I've performed an
accurate threat assessment using my flow
chart of War I should still have the
Tactical Advantage alright so before I
put the flowchart of War to the test
let's recap before a fight I must study
the geography assess the threat
formulate a plan and compare my
situation with the threats if I have the
perceived Advantage I will lead with
deception and strike with deception if I
have the perceived disadvantage then I
will tactically Retreat or lay low in
some cases if the moment is right I will
bewildered with diplomacy
wait hold up man let's team up let's
team up let's team up
don't shoot let's team up let's team up
let's team up
this hold on hold on let's team up you
want to team up
you want to work together
don't shoot don't you okay
green Poncho let's team up
how you make me do that
green Poncho don't shoot green Poncho
let's work together
[Music]
hey man I know you're in there you want
to team up
let's work together
[Music]
okay diplomacy it's guns blazing from
now on well after I've properly analyzed
the threat in one evening shortly after
creating the flow chart of War I walked
away with not one but two chicken
dinners
I haven't played pubg in years and even
when I was playing regularly my chicken
dinner rate was embarrassingly low
sometimes I'd go weeks without a proper
win so my flow chart of war was working
everyone else out here is playing
checkers and I am playing chess it isn't
perfect though and my guy Sun Tzu over
here never accounted for all these
cracked Gamers out here on God or
whatever whatever the kids say these
days I could read this book a dozen more
times and still be aiming my
Elite tactics help sure but sometimes
the other guy behind the monitor is just
better than me
obviously I got outmaneuvered somewhat
regularly and met an untimely demise but
I couldn't help but notice my improved
win rate it did come at a cost though I
was really annoying to Squad up
with all right coming up behind coming
up behind uh take it slow take it slow
crouch crouch crouch I I can hear you
get down get down get down don't shoot
don't shoot don't shoot yep yep get down
get down let's wait give it I just said
not to shoot
look to your right to your right to your
right okay get out of the car we don't
we don't need the car right now get out
of the car winning was nice but honestly
I don't really game to win I game to
hang out with friends not to mention
calling out plays and always thinking 20
steps ahead was exhausting I really
started to hate myself after a couple
days of this and I was gravitating to
far more relaxing games like breath of
the wild I wonder if there's some sort
of balance I could strike dedicate one
of my brain cells to Tactical
coordination and the other one to just
having fun with friends or maybe I just
don't game for Glory sure I love winning
especially when it comes to Smash Bros
but after a long day of work I just want
to shoot stuff with Pals I feel like
with streaming culture Esports and
challenge modes it's easy to get caught
up in the skill aspect of gaming what's
your KD what are your reaction times and
so on it's cool if that's your thing and
that's why you play games don't get me
wrong but maybe it's okay to just be
mediocre or dare I say bad at them but
that kind of brings us to the point of
this episode and no HUD in general play
games how you want if you want to go for
Glory then go for Glory if you want to
mess around then mess around and if you
want to play games to catch up with
friends then do exactly that and don't
let anyone tell you otherwise thank you
for checking out this episode of no HUD
please leave a comment down below of
what you'd like to see next and we'll
see you next time